درجات الحرارة التي يتم الإبلاغ عنها خارج
بورتلاند أوريغون محيرة للعقل ، فهذه
ليست ساخنة فقط ، بل من الخطورة
أن تحطم درجات الحرارة القياسية طوال
الوقت مع ارتفاع درجة حرارة الكوكب ،
سنبحث عن المزيد من الطرق للتغلب على
الحرارة التي كان على الكثير من الناس القيام بها  الاندفاع إلى
محطات التبريد عندما تفقد الطاقة
حسابات تكييف الهواء لـ 10 من إجمالي
استهلاك الكهرباء العالمي
ومن المتوقع أن يتضاعف الطلب على هذا النوع من التبريد
ثلاث مرات بحلول عام 2050 مما
قد يجهد الشبكات الكهربائية التي تعمل بالفعل فوق
طاقتها حيث تحصل على مكيفات هواء أكثر سخونة تحتاج أنظمة التبريد إلى مزيد من الطاقة
لتشغيل المزيد من الكهرباء التي نستخدمها
للتبريد ، كلما زادت صعوبة
التشغيل وتوفير الكهرباء بشكل موثوق ،
وهذا هو السبب في أن مهمة شركة sky cool هي
جعل أنظمة التبريد الحالية
تعمل بكفاءة أكبر من خلال الاستفادة
من ظاهرة موجودة في الطبيعة
تنطلق جميع الكائنات  الحرارة في شكل
إشعاع تحت أحمر غير مرئي
حيث تترك الحرارة جسمًا يصبح
أكثر برودة وهي عملية معروفة  للتبريد الإشعاعي ،
لكن يمكن أن تصبح بعض الأشياء بالفعل
أكثر برودة من الهواء المحيط بها ، وهذا
جزء من سبب تشكل الصقيع على العشب
حتى لو كانت درجة حرارة الهواء أعلى من
درجة التجمد ، ولكن هذا يحدث فقط في الليل
بمجرد شروق الشمس ، حيث ترتفع درجة حرارة العشب في
نهاية المطاف حتى ترتفع درجة حرارة
السماء.  تم تصميم مادة جديدة ذات
خصائص تبريد إشعاعية تعمل على
مدار 24 ساعة في اليوم ،
بمعنى أننا نفعل ذلك
لم يكن موجودًا بالفعل قبل أن
يتم ملاحظة التأثير مطلقًا خلال النهار ومن خلال
تمكينه مع هذه الأفلام التي  لقد تم
تطويره يمكنك الآن استخدام هذا النوع من
التبريد حتى عندما يكون تحت أشعة الشمس المباشرة التي تم
تطويرها باستخدام
تقنية النانو الحديثة ، يحتوي الفيلم على مئات
الطبقات الضوئية الدقيقة المصممة لإصدار
طول موجي معين من الإشعاع الذي
يزيد التبريد إلى أقصى حد ، ولكنه أيضًا
عاكس للغاية يمتص القليل من الطاقة لذلك
يظل باردًا حتى تحت أشعة الشمس ،
حيث لم يتم العثور على تركيبة من الخصائص
في الطبيعة
التي تشبهها بشكل لا يصدق
أنا تقريبًا عمى لكن هل هم في
الواقع رائعون جسديًا عند لمسهم
أعمى تمامًا وأحرق نفسي في نفس الوقت ،
نعم
أي سطح آخر على السطح سيكون
أكثر برودة بكثير ، نعم إنهم أكثر برودة
مما أنا عليه  أتوقع أن أعني أن الجو حار
إنه يوم حار وهذا رائع
للمس ، نعم
هذه صورة بالأشعة تحت الحمراء للألواح
الموجودة على سطحنا يمكنك أن ترى أن هناك
تباينًا صارخًا حقًا في درجة الحرارة
بين الأسطح التي تمثل
أفلام التبريد الإشعاعي هذه و  ثم
سقف المبنى وما هو هذا
الاختلاف في درجة الحرارة سيكون
في حدود 40 فهرنهايت كما
يبدو ولأن الألواح لا تحتاج إلى
أي كهرباء لتبريد السماء الباردة
تقول إنها يمكن أن تساعد نظام تبريد المبنى في
العمل  طاقة أقل ، إليك
كيفية تبريد الألواح أولاً للمياه التي
تمر عبر الأنابيب المضمنة خلفها ،
ثم يتدفق الماء البارد إلى
نظام التبريد أو تكييف الهواء
للمساعدة في تبريد سائل التبريد الذي
يستغرق شيئًا  من عبء العمل خارج
المكثف ، كلما قل تشغيل المكثف
، تم توفير المزيد من الأموال في فاتورة الطاقة ،
أي شيء يمكننا القيام به لتخفيف
بعض الحمل عن شبكات الطاقة ،
أنا كل شيء بالنسبة له
في عام 2019 ، قمت بتثبيت ألواحها من sky cool  في
متجر البقالة هذا في ستوكتون بكاليفورنيا ،
حيث يكون الجو حارًا وجافًا
معظم العام ، يقول المتجر إنه شهد
فرقًا ملحوظًا بعد أن قمنا
بتثبيت نظام التبريد السماوي لدينا ،
رفعت شركة الكهرباء أسعارها علينا
لم نكن نرى فاتورتنا ترتفع
في الواقع ، شهدنا انخفاضًا طفيفًا ،
لقد وفرنا في المتوسط حوالي 3000 دو
ار شهريًا وم
ذ ذلك الحين قامت skycool بتركيب لوحات في مت
ر بيع بالتجزئة في جنوب كاليفورنيا وم
كز بيانات في سكرامنتو يساعد في تب
يد خوادم الكمبيوتر في ال
هاية تأمل skycool في  قم بإحضار
الألواح الموفرة للطاقة إلى المباني التجارية الأخرى
، وفي يوم من الأيام إلى أسطح
المنازل في المستقبل ، يمكنك تخيل
استخدام هذا على أسطح المباني غير المعزولة
في آسيا أو إفريقيا والهند
حيث تتوقع  لنكون بلايين من
مكيفات الهواء الجديدة التي ستأتي عبر الإنترنت
خلال الثلاثين عامًا القادمة ، أعتقد أننا
متحمسون للغاية لكوننا قادرين على استخدام هذه
التقنية الجديدة للأفضل
[موسيقى]